Has the Joe the past.
I hear you.
I don't want to be right about
them killing babies. That doesn't,
I know you don't want to be, want to be
round about a human. You don't have to be.
You don't, it means it doesn't matter
whether you want to be right here. Oh,
Jesus. What's your longest podcast?
We're going, no, don't do that.
That was like six hours or
something. [inaudible] I think. Uh,
Kevin Smith was along this. He was like
five and a half. Fuck that dude. Oh,
he's a great guy. Just kidding.
I love him. Okay. 30 more
minutes. I want to give up.
You're going to get shanked
up to, I'm fine, man. Will
ours look. Here's the thing.
Fine. Listen, I'll be honest
with you. I'm kind of retarded
in that. No, no, no. That's
going to be a soundbite.
They're going to put that
to Mariachi music. No,
I might have to use it. You must be
flame thrower to light. The next choice.
I'll take a poll of
tobacco. No, no. Seriously.
When it comes to regular life,
regular tobacco with no marijuana at all.
Would you like some? Yes. Okay.
Dell, but I know lead for hours.
My Gut never wrong.
That's all your your points. Cause
here's the deal. What points?
That's all I got back. 100%.
100% ain't got no points.
He's got some great points.
No, no. Eddie, Eddie,
big UFC Basadur of the flat
earth society. No, he's not.
Eddie barely listened to anybody.
Doesn't believe more than he believes.
Everybody fluttered
became a universal truth.
He would fucking start
believing the earth is round.
No Flat Earth Society contraries front.
The flatter society is
controlled opposition. Nobody
gets in flatter. Okay, listen,
I know there's a lot of bullshit.
So I run her society. It's not real.
I respect you. I do. I
love you. The point is,
is that I'm asking you a
real question here. Okay.
It'd be the biggest documentary
in history. It only costs
like $1 million. Okay?
Let's take it that 50,000 ton big
ship and to have it shirk them.
Navigate the planet, okay? You will
be there with GP and no, no, no, no.
I'm not going to be there.
Fuck No.
We're going to get someone to represent
me there. Okay. All right. Good drugs.
We're launching God doing no, no, no, no.
We're launching the discovery of flat
earth project. Well, that rocket man,
Dude's already shooting himself in
the space, isn't he? Like, yeah,
it's really easy. You know, you know, you
prove the earth. We really live on a ball.
How when you, when they supposedly
make those missions to the ISS,
when they shoot up,
just have the one of the astronauts,
it's going to go to the ISS.
Just have a GoPro camera on his head,
on his helmet and just go uncut.
No cuts, no cuts from the tongue.
You get on that ship to the tongue.
You Doc, and I want you to duck
and Fred. Fred, no fricking
technology. It'll be my up.
I got my phone is awesome.
Let's listen to what does that Eddie,
the suck be combative here, but if
that combat deaths talk, I know,
but you're talking over each other.
If that did happened, would you a,
you want some tobacco,
Alex Jones.
And that happened lots of pure amount
in the first time. I'm saying this.
I've been saying if that happens,
if that happened, you let it go.
There's no footage of the construction
of the international space station.
There was no footage. You just
appeared cause they're not as feathers.
Painters of the modules
of the international,
I you sure about that 100% there's
no footage of the construction.
That shit. I've known people
that worked on the space station.
I've known astronauts. They're
real people, man. They were,
they know they are real people.
I didn't say to her real piece,
so you don't think it's really constructed
or you would like to see the footage
first? Listen, listen. If you know there's
a, there's a debate. Let me finish, dude.
Let me just, there's a debate, uh,
out there whether you believe he
went to the moon or not. You have,
everyone needs to acknowledge it.
There's a debate. There's people,
what am I the laser? Hold on, hold on.
There's people that believe we went to
the moon and there's people believed that
we faked it. You have to understand
both resalable ever necessary. Exactly.
Exactly. So when you talk about, uh,
the people that don't
believe we went to the moon,
when they also say they're
faking other space shit too,
you have to kind of understand where
they're coming from. Moon mission.
They believe whether we win or not. Maybe
we were, maybe we didn't. I don't know.
But there's people that don't believe it,
so when they don't,
you should understand it. They have no
trust for any of that as I love you.
How many times you've got to fake
going to the moon before you go, okay,
well before that bullshit meter
just fucking explodes. No, I agree.
Let's [inaudible] probably got mad about
Sandy Hook, which I think happened.
I have a right to question.
Hold on.
I was watching minions three or four
where they go to us and they run through
the minions, you know, run through
Hollywood and they're staying in them.
And lighting people have a
right to do that. The true,
there's nobody wants to send people up
cause a bunch of die a bunch of test
Palestine. We fly on jumbo jets around
the country, our cell phones work.
Do you think that we definitely went to
the moon? Absolutely. 100%. Absolutely.
Bet Your life on it that my life.
But the difference is is that they say,
I say it didn't happen.
The truth says that we have f type
of Alex Jones and i's moon landing.
I've denied it a bunch
of times. They, you know,
they say Alex Jones says that there are a,
you are a human slaves on Mars.
Ever said it.
But all I'm saying is I know
the real NASA people and
Wernher von Braun, the guy who directed
all six blue missions was a Nazi, correct?
Yes. Uh, he uh, he hung out
with uh, a Walt Disney, correct?
Yeah. Yeah. And who in the 50s
just made up space? They never,
no one would ever went to space.
How is space?
What Elisha had space while I was on
the phone with you for 45 minutes this
morning.
I told you I have a 12 inch telescope.
12 inch diameter opening aperture. Yes. I
talked to him. Look, it's a fricking mode.
You're taking 35 millimeter photos there.
It's there.
All the shit you see when
you look up it's there.
You get kind have a total scope.
You can closer to what's going on.
We're not going to have a
space is fake conversation.
You told me the fucking why can't I
can't do this? I didn't say the lights.
I don't know.
Well I don't know what they are.
The way I describe this is the
same way I talk about Jujitsu. You,
you should never talk about how effective
martial arts art can prove that shit.
You can't do all this thing can prove
that the sun is 93 million miles.
You don't think like scientists.
You've got to believe that we believe
are real people that have souls and
freewill. Cause you could say maybe
we don't even exist. You don't exist.
Joe Doesn't exist and nobody exists.
So because we can have a space for your
talk fucking head but break. No. Great.
Let's not do it. Nope. The
only, my point of all that was,
I don't want to have it
spaced discussion either.
But my point is that if there's people
out there that believe we faked going to
the moon six times, you have to
understand their skepticism. That's, yes,
this is, hold on. You know what I mean?
We actually talked about before when
he was talking to him. That's all.
This is what we talked about before when
he was talking about the reason why he
questions anything. It's cause he's,
he's seen so many different things.
It turned out to be exactly [inaudible]
earlier and he was actually saying that
sometimes you can get fucking crazy with
it and you think that everything's fake
and you call bullshit on things
that really aren't. But I,
human exploration is real.
Yes.
We can do some stuff like what have you,
we've done man.
Um,
what like what like fight wars and shit.
Like what? Like I like, that's awesome.
Tesla, right? Yeah. Right. Where's Tesla?
I know. Just how about all the technology
that you enjoy and make your life?
I love it. I love them
signs. That's of course,
of course I talking to [inaudible]
allows people to understand the distance
between earth and Mars. That's
the same, this kind of stuff.
Then you get into rumors,
but by the way,
you've taught me a lot.
You're a really smart guy and
entrepreneur and a badass show.
I think it's healthy to be where you're
at. Questioning everything first,
just buying everything. All I'm telling
you is is the stuff we have now.
A hundred years ago it would be considered
magic and we humans getting, wait, yes,
I agree with that.
Fucking iPhones.
I know people that [inaudible]
hospital and nothing that side,
just on the main line in the
videos running NASA and I'm like,
where are we there? Yes.
I ran the RCA cameras.
We faked the photos because the radiation
belts in it, they dogged him up,
but when we shouldn't have done that,
I fucking know what happened.
That makes way more sense to me and it's
one of the things that Jamie and I have
actually discussed when we
talked about the Gemini 15 photo,
the famous photo of Michael Collins.
That turns out to be just a reverse of
a photo of him on a training mission
where he's in the harness.
One old PR, they use it.
That's why I said a little overzealous
PR agents. I didn't go to too.
I went to three
beds of NASA engineers.
One of them was Raymond take that
allowed me to talk about this.
Raymond was there running this Frickin,
he ran the lasers on the moon.
He ran the deals.
He said what was weird is they had
another group of ships and I'm out,
you know it be him, told me I will
say this, I just shouldn't do it.
Another group of ships,
well they got another group of sheriffs,
but basically he wouldn't
say it and this is not drama.
I was going to meet with him. I met with
him at the former Norad Command base.
That's the Hilton outside Austin and he
wouldn't tell me and then like a week
later his heart blew, but he was ready
to tell me. He said, no, it's real,
but there's more advanced and he had
like presidential letters, his house.
You look at him, he's like the
main guy, like running the cameras,
like number three in Nasa, like for
engineers, fricking g he was in Vietnam,
ran black ops and Cambodia and he said,
he said,
well we lost a lot of people,
but those were clandestined operations.
I wasn't part of them. It's all
compartmentalized. But he said,
you're right that there were a bunch of
missions beforehand because the US was
willing to kill 50 people to do that,
just to see if they can get some,
so no one else will do. It was a tragic
thing to us. Is that great Joe? No,
we were willing to, we had
men who are ready to die. Oh,
over and over again for the one time it
worked and that's what pisses me off.
Well, Gus Grisham in those,
the original blew up on them.
Line phone blew up on the launchpad.
You know,
we'll be incredibly tragic if is if
they actually did go to the moon,
but they fake the footage because of the
radiation. So their releases bullshit.
No,
but do you know how,
how horrific that would be if you were
a guy like Neil Armstrong and you knew
that the footage was bullshit,
but you actually had gone to
the moon and you're like fuck.
And this whole thing was like, people
were starting a little, why are these,
what does it look like? They're
on wires. There's eyes good.
They're on trampolines.
Like yeah. By the way,
they all got radiated cause it's true.
Like he says going through that,
it's like a thousand chest x rays or
something. You know? Even if it's noon,
you know it's like 10 texts Chessa
right? Yeah. Terrible for you. Notice,
although I thought it was only one.
Notice how they know it's more notice
how the international flights are all now
at night. Why is that? Because
there's freaking know. Ready Dude.
So did you go to sleep?
It's a red. No, no, no.
Solar radiation from
35,000 feet to two two.
She level on average is 10 feet of
water and about six inches of stone.
There's dirt. Why? Why is the
sun so big on the, on the,
explain that again. What are you saying?
Imagine that the atmosphere is a lens.
Okay.
So when you,
why do you think the sun or the moon
look so much bigger on that rise?
Why is that? You ever thought about that?
I always thought it was just refraction.
Harrison. [inaudible] I'm
bigger than clothes. Why is red?
Why is it red? The atmosphere, you're
looking at all more care and yeah,
you're looking through a thousand
miles instead of 20 miles. Okay.
Show the moon gets smaller and her
totally wide as it goes up. Right.
So this is listens like astronomy.
I'm on.
I see what you're saying because you're
looking at it on the, on the plane.
[inaudible] I forget. Uh, we
were talking about that flights.
Yeah. Radiation we're talking about
already or shield, whatever it is.
You get a bunch of chest x rays when
you fly during the day because the sun
solar radiation because you're above,
everybody knows you're in the mountains.
You get a worst sunburn.
Why?
Let's oxygen less dropping the v the UV.
Yeah. Show when you're at 35,000 feet.
That's above the Himalayas. Yeah.
You, you are up there. And there's no,
there's, there's on average 35,000 feet.
This is NASA [inaudible]
probably not true.
[inaudible] feet of water and six
inches of stone stick as theirs.
If you can densed 35,000 feet of dust,
the filter. Oh Wow. Why won't you hit a
filter on your iPhone as it turned out?
The color put a filter over.
Right. She'll think about,
think about the atmosphere when you're
looking straight up the boons fucking
white looking at this
angle. It's yellow, right?
It's big and orange on the
like, damn, that's big.
It's not just where it's coming up.
That's part of it. It's that itch.
It's bubbled, it's deformed. You're,
it's like looking through a
pair of glasses on the edge.
So you're looking through all that
atmosphere you look at through pollution,
through dirt, everything. Yeah.
Yeah. My Dad told me all that.
That's fucking a manger now.
So that's why moons are red.
They're red when they arise, they're
white. Where they go to the top.
It's all this shit. We're
looking at it through. Yeah,
we've got a weird situation,
Huh?
A big ass one quarter
sized planet just floating,
just floating above us. We stare at
it. Well, it's a full moon tonight.
That is fucking weird. Is a planet.
It's right there. I I, yeah.
I fell asleep at like 10 o'clock last
night and missed your call and I woke up
at like three 30 and I had to get up and
I looked out, it looked fake news show.
Sometimes it's a half moon and I was
looking out of the hotel like 500 yards,
Shamir, and I'm looking at beautiful.
That is, it's just like, hey,
it's okay to say it's made out of
cheese. Did you? Probably, isn't it.